i don't think there are any winners here
either on the police side or on andrew
mitchell's side in terms of the damage
that was done we have an officer who is
in prison somebody who claimed that they
were there at the time who in fact
wasn't there we had a meeting with
andrew mitchell and a local branch of
the police federation where clearly
their account of what happened in that
meeting was wasn't true either but the
central figures
it looks like the pc you had the
encounter comes out of it with a clean
record was andrew mitchell wrong to try
and pursue this in this way do you think
i was very nervous uh about the libel uh
action adam i thank the good lord that i
am born poor
and i'm as poor as a church mouse so
that when i was done over by the news of
the world 20 years ago the question of
suing them never arose because i simply
couldn't afford it and uh um but but
andrew has maintained to me as you've
indicated i've known him for 35 years i
was in the house of commons with him and
his father we worked together as
governor whips and he's a very dear
friend of mine and he will be the same
friend tomorrow as he's been up until
today
but i was nervous about libel actions
because it's a throw of the dice
i believe absolutely everything that
andrews told me the lesson that i would
say
that a cabinet minister should learn is
the reason you're given a government car
is for a reason uh and my beef with
andrew right where it goes
never ride a bike and i was very angry
with him on day one uh for uh doing all
this pr nonsense that the cameroons want
them all to do i mean brian panic to a
certain extent um
it's not a battle of equals is it
because as i understand it if you're a
serving police officer you're backed by
the police federation which as we know
has very deep pockets so had he lost
uh it wouldn't actually tell you to runs
wouldn't have had to pay up himself
whereas this effectively could ruin
andrew mitchell
well
this
poor pc had a an ex-cabinet minister
accusing him of lying on the front pages
of most of the national newspapers it
put that officer in a very difficult
position the priest federation have
resorted to suing people on many
occasions when they've been criticized
haven't they and the people involved are
protected because the police federation
is i can't think of another case where
there's an operational police officer
has been accused of lying and as a
result the police federation backed that
officer to sue the person involved this
is a one-off unique case in my opinion
and pc roland says what that he gave an
honest account the judge believed him
and that's the bottom line do you have
any